in this lesson we're going to talk about
the geometric mean theorems involving
the altitude and the leg and we're going
to go through this video in three parts
the first part we're going to just talk
about how to use the formulas we're
going to do three problems involving the
altitude then we're going to do three
problems involving the leg and then at
the very end the third section we're
going to talk about why these theorems
actually work and where they come from
and how to derive them again if you want
to understand that at a deeper level so
let's dive in so the first thing we want
to realize here is that when you have a
right triangle and you drop an altitude
what ends up happening is you end up
with these three triangles the small
triangle medium triangle and this
overall triangle and there's some
relationships that develop because these
are similar triangles that we can set up
some proportions and you probably
remember from earlier in math when you
learned about the cross multiplying we
call it the cross product and basically
what it is that this diagonal multiplied
together equals this diagonal multiplied
together the proper name for that was
actually the means extremes property and
the means are like these two guys right
here and the extremes are these two guys
right here and so what we say here is
that the altitude is the geometric mean
of A and B so what that means is this
altitude is the geometric mean of the
two parts of the hypotenuse that it's
dividing it up into so that's the
theorem that we're going to work with
first in these first three problems so
for number one you can see that here's
our altitude it's a right triangle we're
dropping that altitude the altitude
X is the geometric mean of the two parts
of the hypotenuse that it splits it up
into then we can use that cross
multiplying or cross product or means
extremes property however you want to
call that and you're going to get x
times x is x squared equals 2 times 8
which is 16 and then if we take the
square root of both sides you can see
that that altitude X is going to be
four units
okay so for example number two
here we're actually solving for this
little part of the hypotenuse okay and
they're giving us the altitude but we
can still use this altitude geometric
mean theorem we would set it up like
this we'd say okay our altitude 5 is the
geometric mean of the two parts of the
hypotenuse that it's splitting up into
so that's X and four then when we do our
cross product you can see we have 4
times x
is equal to 25 and if we divide both
sides by 4 you can see that X is coming
out to 25 4.
and then the third example here with the
altitude theorems as you can see we're
actually looking for this other part of
the hypotenuse right here and they're
giving us the altitude in this whole
hypotenuse here what you want to do is
again use the altitude geometric mean
theorem but if this whole hypotenuse is
10 this part is X how long is this piece
right here
well that would be the total 10 minus
this part we don't want X and that's
going to leave us with 10 minus X so now
we can set this up and say that our
altitude 4
is the geometric mean of
this part of the hypotenuse and this
part of the hypotenuse so 10 minus x and
x so now we can cross
multiply and do that means extremes
property and you can see that we've got
let's see x times 10 minus X is equal to
4 times 4 which is 16. we can distribute
the X we're getting uh 10 x minus x
squared is equal to 16. let's go ahead
and get everything on one side of the
equation and set it to zero so I'm going
to add x squared over here so that makes
that positive x squared I'm going to
subtract 10x
and the 16 is already on the right so
that's plus 16 is equal to 0. now what
we can do is we can Factor this and set
the factors equal to zero so if we
Factor this it's going to factor to x
minus 8 times x minus 2 if you need to
you can go back to some of my factoring
videos to learn more about factoring but
you can see negative 8 and negative 2
multiplied to positive 16 but the inside
negative 8X and the outside negative 2x
add up to the middle negative 10x so now
if we set x minus 8 equal to zero
you can see that X is going to be equal
to 8 and if we set x minus 2 equal to 0
to 2. so essentially you can see that if
I put 8 in here this length could be 2
right and then this other part would be
8 or if we put 2 in here this part could
be 8 and the other part could be two so
let's go ahead and take a look now at
the leg
geometric mean theorems okay now let's
talk about how to work with the leg
theorem okay so the leg theorem we've
got this leg of the right triangle and
we have this leg of the right triangle I
just called this one leg number one and
leg number two and what you want to
remember with the leg theorem is that
the leg is the geometric mean of the
whole hypotenuse and the part of the
hypotenuse that's adjacent to that leg
closest to that leg so if you're dealing
with leg number two then you'd say the
leg number two is the geometric mean of
the whole hypotenuse length and the part
of the hypotenuse next to that leg B so
let's go through three examples so you
can see how this works so for number
four I can see I've got that right
triangle I can see I've got that
altitude and so what I'm going to say is
that this leg here Acts
is the geometric mean
of the whole hypotenuse so I'll have to
add these together to get 12 and the
part of the hypotenuse that's adjacent
to that leg which is 4. now if we cross
multiply across the equal sign you can
see we're getting x squared is equal to
and you can see that 48 is really like
let's take the square root of both sides
so we can see that X is equal to the
square root of 48 and square root of 48
is really 16 times 3
and the square root of 16 is 4. so this
is coming out to 4 square root of 3.
for the length of our leg
now for number five you can see this is
the leg that we're trying to solve for
and so we would say that's this leg
number two theorem you can see leg two
is the geometric mean of the whole
hypotenuse and the part of the
hypotenuse adjacent to that leg so what
this one's going to look like is you're
going to have leg number two is the
geometric mean of the whole hypotenuse
which is 11 and the part of the
hypotenuse that's adjacent to that leg
again we're just going to cross multiply
across the equal sign that's going to
give us x times x x squared is equal to
11 times 9.99 take the square root of
both sides and you can see that let's
see what does that come out to well
let's do this square root of 99 is 9
times 11 and we know that the square
root of 9 is 3 so that's going to be 3
square root of 11. and for number six
now this problem here they're giving us
this leg of the right triangle the whole
hypotenuse but we really need the part
of the hypotenuse that's adjacent to
that leg right so we're using this
theorem right here so leg number one the
two root two
is the geometric mean
of the whole hypotenuse which is X
and the part of the hypotenuse adjacent
to that leg so if this whole thing is X
and this part right here is 2 this must
be x minus 2 the total minus what we
don't want
so that's x minus 2. okay now if we
cross multiply across that equal sign
what do we get well we get x times x
minus 2 equals 2 root 2 times 2 root two
two times two is four square root of 2
times square root of 2 is 2. 4 times 2
is 8.
and then if we distribute you can see
we're getting x squared minus 2X equals
8. let's get everything on one side of
the equation
by subtracting 8 and setting it to zero
and then we'll Factor
and set the factors to zero so this
factors to x minus four
and X plus 2 because negative 4 times 2
is negative 8 negative 4X and positive
2x adds up to the negative 2X and then
if we set these factors equal to zero
and solve you can see if we add 4 to
both sides x equals 4 or here we get x
equals negative 2. now could this really
be a negative 2 length no so this is
extraneous solution so it's just going
to be X is equal to 4. and you got it so
let's take a look next about
understanding where these formulas come
from how you can you know get them back
and derive them if you ever get stuck
and you forget the formulas so let's
talk about that next so let's label the
angles in this right triangle so we've
got this right triangle we drop an
altitude let's call this angle here in
the lower left corner Theta
that means that this angle here has to
be 90 minus Theta because in a right
triangle the two acute angles have to
add up to 90. so say if this was 20 this
would have to be 90 minus 20 70 or if
this was 60 90 minus 60 30. so whatever
this angle is this angle has to be 90
minus that angle that's the complement
but if this is 90 minus Theta this angle
has to be Theta because together they
have to add up to 90 this right angle
like if this was uh let's say this was
40 this would have to be 50 because 40
plus 50 adds up to the 90. but if this
angle is Theta this has to be 90 minus
Theta because these two have to add up
to 90 because this is a right triangle
so what happens is if we take a look at
this little triangle I'm going to put it
right here
I'm going to take this medium triangle
here I'm going to take it I'm going to
rotate it okay like a quarter turn
that's going to be this triangle right
here and then if we take this entire
triangle we're going to have to
turn it and move it over here like that
okay so you can see that what I've done
is I've positioned them all in the same
orientation such that you've got Theta
over here and you've got 90 minus Theta
over here and all these triangles are
similar so you learned earlier in
Geometry about the angle angle
similarity theorem meaning if two angles
in one triangle like for example see
these are both Theta these are both 90.
so if two angles in one triangle are
congruent to two angles and another
triangle then the triangles are similar
and the ratio of the corresponding sides
will be proportional and that's where we
get these theorems from so I'll show you
so for this one if we were to look at
the altitude
we can see that let's take a look at
these two triangles right here so we can
say that the ratio of this side to this
side see a to the altitude is the ratio
of the altitude to B so all I'm doing is
if I slide this triangle over this side
matches up with this side so the ratio
of a to the altitude is the same as the
ratio of that altitude to B this leg to
this leg so that's where the altitude
theorem comes from now for the leg
theorem let's say leg number one we
would take this triangle and the overall
triangle so we would say that
the hypotenuse of this triangle matches
up with the leg one of this Triangle C
hypotenuse hypotenuse so hypotenuse to
leg one okay that ratio is the same as
leg one
to a so you'd leg one to a we're just
matching up the corresponding sides
making a proportion and the last one if
you compare these two triangles you can
see the hypotenuse in this triangle
matches up with the hypotenuse in this
triangle which we happen to call leg two
okay that ratio is the same as this leg
leg two
to B so again you're just matching up
the corresponding sides of similar
triangles so if you ever forget you can
draw that out and draw the three
triangles and make a proportion but
these are just designed to be shortcuts
so if you're enjoying the channel and
you want to support what I'm doing here
on YouTube consider becoming a channel
member for a few dollars a month you can
support the channel and I really
appreciate that I also have an algebra 1
and Algebra 2 video course for sale you
can check those out in the description
below if you're interested in that and
if you want to do some more examples
with geometric mean I'll put a video
right there follow me over there and
we'll get some more practice